among the primal fitness crowd there is
the notion that there's a natural
optimal way to move live and train we've
distanced ourselves from the environment
that shaped our evolution
and as such this is what has introduced
so many of our modern maladies
while i agree with this to some extent i
do feel that it simplifies matters
somewhat and it could be a limited
perspective
because the real superpower of the human
body is adaptability
look at modern indigenous tribes the
closest thing we have to natural humans
and we see
huge variations in their lifestyles and
abilities
the tarahumara tribe are capable of
running distances of
200 miles in a single session the bajao
sea nomads feature enlarged
spleens that allow them to die for up to
13 minutes at a time
the peraha people take naps of 15
minutes to 2 hours at most they don't
sleep for a single stint
which of these is natural and throughout
our evolution we would have encountered
countless more unique challenges and
environments
we are malleable and impermanent we now
know that the brain is capable of
rewiring itself in mass via brain
plasticity
to the extent that it's possible to lose
an entire hemisphere
and see enough rewiring in the remaining
half of the brain
to retain the majority of cognitive
function to the extent that a blind
person can learn to navigate their
environment with
sonar even our bones are constantly
being broken down and reabsorbed
they've been likened to banks for
storing minerals all these abilities
will allow us to evolve and to thrive in
nearly any environment
and this is why we can actually look at
things like kyphosis anterior pelvic
tilts
obesity short attention spans and poor
hip and ankle mobility as
adaptive these are adaptations to
sitting to surviving on plentiful albeit
processed food
to using the internet moreover unlike
many cultures before us we've adapted
our environments to us
nearly everything in our environment is
the perfect height such that we don't
need to stoop or to climb
we are lean mean sitting and walking
machines
that is not wrong but if you want to be
able to kick ass if you want to be
strong to be useful
then this environment will develop a
limited skill set
many people will attempt to change this
by returning to what they see as more
natural movement patterns and lifestyles
they do this with workouts that last 30
to 60 minutes four times a week
training for three hours out of 168 each
week is a drop in the ocean
those movements are anomalies you're not
giving your body the incentive to adapt
because for the vast majority of the
time it still doesn't need to
so perhaps you push harder to try and
create more stimulus in that short space
of time
and of course you injure yourself your
body is not prepared for that kind of
movement
if you really want to trigger profound
changes the need to change the
environment
change the environment change the
organism because i mean your habits
the way you move the way you think push
yourself to keep learning and growing
and don't be limited by what you think
is natural for the human body
your scope and potential is nearly
limitless so the only question is
what do you want to become
so if you found this video useful and
interesting guys something a little bit
different if you did please leave a like
and share around that helps me out
immensely and if you like the idea of
this uncommon training and
a more philosophical approach to fitness
then you might enjoy my ebook and
training program
super functional training you'll find a
link to that in the description down
below and there's currently a discount
on whilst many of us are still stuck in
lockdown
be sure to check out grant's channel
i'll put the link to that in the
description down below as well
he's now uploading weekly tutorials on
various different martial arts moves
and the first one on the spin hook kick
is awesome
so thanks a ton for watching guys hope
you're all doing well and i'll see you
soon
bye for now